MESSAGE.
TELL YOUR REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
MEANT SENATORS TO WATCH.
WE HAVE ALL OF THAT NEW
INFORMATION AND TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT WE START WITH THE
BOMBSHELL DEVELOPMENT ABOUT
FORMER DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE RED FOX NEWS
TONIGHT REPORTING THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
IS RENEWING STOMACH REVIEWING A
DECLARATION TO GIVE McCABE THE
ACTS AND SOURCES ARE TELLING
FOX NEWS THAT FIRING McCABE
BEFORE FRIDAY WOULD MEAN HE
WOULD LOSE HIS TAXPAYER-FUNDED
PENSION.
HE SAID TO RETIRE ON SUNDAY,
SOMETHING EXPLOSIVE HAS GONE ON
HERE.
THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT IS RAISING
SPECULATION ABOUT THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ABOUT
THE FBI'S PHONY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION WHERE THE FIX WAS
IN, THAT COULD BE RELEASED SOON.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION HAS DISCOVERED
THAT McCABE WAS NOT
FORTHCOMING ABOUT HIS APPROVAL
FOR AN FBI OFFICIAL TO TALK TO
REPORTERS ABOUT THE BUREAU'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND ACCORDING TO
REPORTS, THIS SCANDAL IS WHAT
FORCED McCABE TO BE REMOVED
FROM THAT POSITION AND PLACED ON
LEAVE.
ACCORDING TO A
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORT
FROM EARLIER THIS YEAR, McCABE
WOULD IN AN ENTIRE MONTH TO
INFORM CONGRESS, REMEMBER THOSE
HUMA ABEDIN EMAILS THAT WERE
FOUND ON ANTHONY WEINER'S
LAPTOP?
WHY WOULD HE WAIT?
OF COURSE THERE WAS THE TEXT
MESSAGE FROM THE TRUNCATING FBI
LOVERS PETER STARK AND LISA PAGE
WHERE THEY MENTIONED TALKING TO
ANDY.
ABOUT THAT INSURANCE POLICY GOD
FORBID IF DONALD TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION.
THEN YOU HAVE McCABE'S WIFE
JILL, SHE TOOK OVER $700,000 OF
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
HILLARY CLINTON'S ALLY TERRY
MACOLA AND ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC
GROUP FOR AN OBSCENE AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS SHOULD NOT BE
CONTEMPLATING A DECISION HERE,
BECAUSE THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUS
AND THE FACTS ARE STARING
SESSION RIGHT IN THE FACE.
McCABE IS CORRECT AND HE'S AS
QUICK AS THEY COME.
HE'S ONE OF THE STATE ACTORS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU
ABOUT AND HE NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND FIRING McCABE
BY THE WAY SHOULD ONLY BE A
START.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT JAMES COMEY,
PETER STRZOK, LISA PAGE, OTHER
TOP OFFICIALS PUT THE FIX IN AND
THEY IGNORED OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE THAT HILLARY CLINTON IN
FACT COMMITTED MULTIPLE
FELONIES.
CLINTON SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROSECUTED, SHE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE MADE IT TO NOVEMBER OF
2016.
IT WAS AN OPEN AND SHUT CASE.
THE EVIDENCE WAS ALL THERE, IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN, THE FIX WAS IN,
IT WAS RIGGED.
THAT'S WHY McCABE, COMEY, AND
ALL THE OTHER TOP FBI OFFICIALS
WHO PLAYED A HAND IN THE
INVESTIGATION INTO CLINTON, THEY
SHOULD BE TERRIFIED TONIGHT
ABOUT THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT THAT WE EXPECT TO COME
OUT ANY DAY NOW.
A PROBE SHOULD BE MADE TO THE
DOJ AND IF YOU BELIEVE IN EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, ALL OF
THESE OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
PROSECUTED.
ALSO BRAND-NEW TONIGHT, LIBERAL
HYPOCRISY REACHES A STUNNING NEW
LEVEL.
THERE HE IS, BERNIE SANDERS
WORKING HIS WAY THROUGH AN
ANTI-SECOND AMENDMENT RALLY ON
THE STEPS OF THE U.S. CAPITOL.
NOTICE, HE IS SURROUNDED BY
ARMED SECURITY GUYS.
BERNIE SANDERS WAS NOT ALONE.
WE HAVE ON THE        OTHER GUNG
WE HAVE ON THE        OTHER GUNA
WE HAVE ON THE        OTHER GUNB
WE HAVE ON THE        OTHER GUNN
WE HAVE ON THE        OTHER GUNG
LEFTISTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR CONGRESSIONAL SOLITARY
WALK-OFF HIS EARS TO SAY ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH.
WE NEED A VOTE NOW.
>> IT IS COMMON SENSE THAT WE
SHOULD GET THE ASSAULT RIFLES
AND THE BANANA CLIPS OFF THE
STREETS.
>> THE NRA HAS BEEN MADE PUBLIC
ENEMY NUMBER ONE AND I'M PROUD
OF IT.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN WE ARE GONNA
WIN!
>> ARE YOU GOING TO DO WHATEVER
IT TAKES TO BEAT THE GUN LOBBY?
>> ARE WE GOING TO BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS?
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS?
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE AND THEN
THERE'S NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO WHO ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED
AND I'D DIE IN A PROTEST IN
NEW YORK CITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
HE HAD TONS OF SECURITY ALSO.
SHAMELESS HYPOCRITES.
THEY STAND IN FRONT OF CROWDS OF
PEOPLE, NO FEAR ABOUT THEIR OWN
PERSONAL SAFETY BECAUSE THEY ARE
SURROUNDED BY ARMED SECURITY,
BUT THEY WOULD DENY THOSE SAME
PROTECTIONS TO AMERICA'S SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
BY THE WAY, HERE'S A QUICK
QUESTION.
IF BEING PROTECTED BY ARMED
POLICE OFFICERS IS GOOD FOR
THESE POLITICIANS, SHOULD ONLY
BE GOOD FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
AMERICA'S SCHOOLS?
PRETTY SIMPLE ANSWER, RIGHT?
HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS ARE
ALWAYS THE CHAMPIONS OF GUN FREE
ZONES EXCEPT PLACES WHERE THEY
WORK?
THERE'S TONS OF SECURITY AT THE
CAPITAL IN THE SAME GOES FOR
HOLLYWOOD LIBERALS.
THOSE POMPOUS AWARD CEREMONIES
HAVE MORE SECURITY THAN
FORT KNOX, BUT IN THEIR MINDS,
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS FOR SCHOOLS TO
TAKE THE SAME PRECAUTION THAT
THEY HAVE.
YOU WANT TO PROTECT AMERICA'S
SCHOOLS AND OUR KIDS, THE
SOLUTIONS ARE OBVIOUS.
I HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THEM ON THIS
SHOW.
IN A COMPREHENSIVE THREAT
SECURITY ASSESSMENT, UNIT
CONTROLLED POINTS OF ENTRY, YOU
NEED TO SECURE THE PERIMETERS,
YOU NEED SCHOOL IDEAS, METAL
DETECTORS, AND CONCEALED CARRY
HIGHLY TRAINED RETIRED FORMER
POLICE AND MILITARY.
BY THE WAY, THE HOUSE TO TAKE A
STEP FORWARD TODAY, THEY
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED A SCHOOL
SAFETY BILL THAT AWARDS GRANT
MONEY TO STOP THE VIOLENCE IN
SCHOOLS.
IT'S A GOOD START, BUT IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
AMERICA'S SCHOOLS DESERVE THE
SAME SECURITY THAT LIBERALS
DEMAND FOR THEMSELVES.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF I.C.E. SLAMMING
NANCY PELOSI FOR DARING TO CALL
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES
THAT RISKED THEIR LIVES EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY
SAFE, NANCY CALLED THEM
COWARDLY.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT NOT ONLY DID SHE SAY THEY
WERE COWARDLY, SHE SAID THAT
I.C.E. WAS TERRORIZING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
YOU TALK ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS, THESE ARE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE FOR THIS COUNTRY EVERY
DAY.
THEY LEAVE THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THEIR HOMES TO
DEFEND THIS NATION, SO HOW DARE
YOU CALL THEM COWARDLY.
TO SAY THAT WORD THAT WE ARE
TERRORIZING THESE COMMUNITIES,
SOME OF THESE HAVE ASSAULT WITH
PEOPLE WERE TERRORIZING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
I.C.E. WENT AND REMOVE THESE
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: NANCY PELOSI AND
LIBERALS ARE MAKING IT CLEAR
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM PUTTING
AMERICAN LIVES IN DANGER TO
PROTECT CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT DACA OR
DREAMERS OR PEOPLE THAT
BENEFITED FROM THE VISA LOTTERY,
BUT THESE LIBERALS LIKE THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA MAYOR LIBBY SCHAFF,
THEIR AIDING AND ABETTING
IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE WILL CAUSE REAL HARM TO
REAL AMERICAN CITIZENS OF REAL
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE HOW ANYONE
COULD DEFEND DOING THIS, BUT THE
LEFT IS AND WE DO IT EVERY DAY.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE ANGEL
PARENTS.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHOSE CHILDREN
WERE KILLED BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE NOW GREATLY DEMANDING
THAT MIRROR SCHAAF FACE
PROSECUTION FOR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, PROTECTING CRIMINALS,
AIDING AND ABETTING, PEOPLE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE COUNTRY IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND THEN COMMIT
OTHER CRIMES.
LIBERALS LIKE TO PRETEND THAT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DON'T COMMIT
CRIMES, BUT THEY'RE LYING WHEN